hello there i'm gav and you've joined me
next to a piece of someone's car
in this video we're going to be
demonstrating that classic method
of breaking a car window using the
smashed up ceramic
of a spark plug these can be pretty
tough i've watched rocks bounce off them
i once
failed to break one with a sledgehammer
this car who made this car
very embarrassing i've actually had this
car door for several years
but i've been putting off making this
video because i was waiting
for a new phantom to be invented and
it's been invented
this is the phantom tmx 7510
at the time of this recording this is
the fastest phantom
what has ever been made at its maximum
resolution of around 720p
will do over 75 000 frames per second
reducing the height of the frame taking
out that resolution will increase the
speed
up to a maximum of 1.75
million frames per second
as we've learned from videos in the past
glass cracks extremely quickly
and even at maximum resolution on this
it's still going to be very fast even
around 75 000 frames a second
but i think we should do it get that
lovely full resolution shot
and then i'll pull out another piece of
glass and maybe we'll get insane
with the frame rate the maximum
resolution of this sensor is
1280 by 800 and at that resolution you
get 70
just over 76 000 frames per second and
i've made myself a preset here that just
shaves a little bit off the vertical
resolution
but it's still inclusive of 720p
and at that resolution we can shoot 82
000 frames per second all right let's
start recording
now every single second that goes by
this camera is taking 82
000 pictures first things first
so it's these jagged edges that are
supposedly gonna do the damage
okay we're all framed up it's a very
dirty window but to be honest that's
helped me focus on it
and uh we're backlighting it to really
light up those cracks
in the glass as they form here we go
so far the embarrassment continues a bit
of a chunky piece here but it does have
a jagged edge so i'm just going to try
that oh
that worked didn't it
[Music]
um
[Applause]
oh that just makes me happy the circle
that
fierce travel it's still so fast
the light as it starts reflecting off
all of the cracks
brightens up the area so much actually
lights up the detail in the spark plug
that's such a crazy effect i've never
seen a glass break
travel in such high resolution
i filmed glass at higher resolutions
like with the 4k
at a thousand but usually you're getting
one or two frames of crack
and there's really no indication of how
fast it is other than
yes it's fast this is like yes it's fast
but and look how fast do you want to go
faster
me too i'm glad we agree hindsight
should have probably put down
top so let's see what we can do
any changes to the width on this camera
will not benefit us in terms of frame
rate the width is always the same
unless you're in a bind mode but the
height
is where we get our speed from let's
push it
let's push our luck
six hundred six hundred well
four video half a million as of this
second this is now the fastest we've
ever shot
on this channel half a million frames a
second so one of the major issues with
being at half a million frames a second
is our exposure time
is one microsecond that's one millionth
of a second putting the shutter angle
any lower puts us below
the microsecond range we're now in
nanoseconds that's 944 nanoseconds
i think as we go down it will actually
reflect
that if we get low enough
i've never i've never seen that before
100 nanoseconds i'm not gonna waste a
ton more money on proper
automotive tempered glass so this
is a 10 cutting board which supposedly
is also tempered glass and because we're
at such a high frame rate
we're only looking at a very thin piece
of it anyway okay i can't actually see
anything
i'm hoping that when i break the glass
the cracks light up the image enough to
see what the
heck is going on okay let's get that one
on
should be enough half a million frames
per second
this is what we're using it's got some
quite nice jagged edges on it
here we go
um
whoa whoa
[Music]
so that was actually just a tiny piece
of the ceramic it didn't have the spark
plug going through it
all right i may be getting carried away
here i've got the camera set to 800 000
frames
a second and the exposure time for each
frame is
around 600 nanoseconds
it's actually very difficult to queue up
because
by turning the knob i'm just skip it
skips like hundreds of thousands of
frames
2 630 minutes of footage from that
we recorded almost 4 million frames
this is an absolutely insane speed
not only can you see the travel
leisurely move from left to right you
can actually see
the travel of the cracks up and down
within that left
to right you can almost follow the front
of each crack and watch where it decides
to go
of around the four million pictures the
camera just took
the crack traveled through the frame at
only 145 of those frames
all right i have one cutting board left
and i think a nice way to finish off
this video be just to drop it
on its edge because tempered glass is
usually weak to impact
on the edges not the phantom down here
we'll just do a nice full rest shot
again
at around 80 000 frames a second
it's just so cool to look at
[Applause]
bye there we have it
i think we've got some top drawer
footage there the jagged edges on these
pieces of spark plug are insanely sharp
and you can you know without any mass
really damaging enough to break a window
not very accurate to throw something so
light the best shot i got was actually
when
the ceramic was still around the shaft
of the spark plug
this thing is my honest review
this thing is bonkers i'm very excited
to use this on other subjects that we've
never been able to capture before
you know like slowing a bullet right
down or that brief moment right at the
start of an explosion
very excited to use this in future and
i'm very excited for other people
in the slo-mo community to get their
hands on this and hopefully it really
opens up some new doors for us
subject-wise if you're excited to see
what we get up to with this beast in the
future make sure you stay subscribed
and i will see you in the next video
thank you very much for watching